(upbeat music)
We're backstage in our beautiful test kitchen
and Ross and I are gonna show you how to make a quick
and cheerful holiday cocktail.
And I call this one, the snowball,
and you'll see why coming up.
We're gonna start with one shot of espresso, all right.
And you can use, yours just chilling in the fridge, I think.
We've teamed up with LG and I've been chilling
my espresso in the LG InstaView refrigerator.
It's called InstaView because you can knock twice
on the glass (knocks), and peek inside
without letting any cold air out.
And then you can take just four ounces of eggnog,
and-
Four ounces of eggnog.
Oh, this looks so good.
(Drew exclaims)
Right.
The color.
It's so pretty.
It's like marbleizing.
And I'm gonna put just a shot of rum in mine.
And I will representing mocktail crew.
Perfect.
And you can take the coffee out too
if you want to make it for the kids,
just have it be fancy eggnog.
I have to show you this really cool thing.
If you put the spoon in, it goes right around the ball.
Like perfectly.
That's very satisfying.
It's a very satisfying drink to make.
It's called a snowball because we're gonna pour
this over the slow melting craft ice spheres
from our InstaView fridge.
And then the holiday garnish.
A sprig of Rosemary, looks like a Christmas tree
and-
Really does.
A little miniature candy cane on the side.
And then I dust it with a little nutmeg.
Oh yeah, that does make it look a little more
Christmasy.
You could also do
powdered sugar, helps you with that look.
(exclaims) Snow!
Snow.
Oh, snow you didn't. (giggles)
Cheers!
Cheers.
This is so tasty.
Check out TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com for the recipe
or Rossipe.
(upbeat music)